- You call yourself Doctor Mike?
- Yeah.
Well that's my name, so.
(laughing)
- Wow.
(upbeat music)
(somber music)
- What's up guys.
I've made my way to LA,
for the streamyawards,
and I decided to take this opportunity
to do another curbside consult
like you've been asking for.
But instead of LA edition,
I decided to do Santa Monica edition.
As you can see, legendary
Santa Monica pier behind me,
I'm about to run around
and answer some questions.
Are you ready?
Wee-woo!
Do you guys wanna be in a YouTube video?
- No thanks.
- Are you sure?
- Yeah.
- Health, health related?
No?
Sir, would you like to
be in a YouTube video?
You sure, think about it.
Five million subscribers.
Come on,
answering health questions.
- If you give me
five million bucks, (mumbles).
- Oh my man's a baller!
What do you think you can do
better to improve your sleep?
- I don't know, I have a
really hard time sleeping,
so that's,
- Okay.
- I don't know (laughs) honestly.
- I feel like
I've tried everything.
- Do you use your cell phone before bed?
- Mostly I'll just like put on YouTube
and try to fall asleep.
- Do you put on night
shift mode on your phone?
- No.
- Okay.
I highly recommend that.
Do you know why?
- Why?
- Because night shift mode,
reduces the amount of blue
light your phone gives off
- Oh.
- And blue light,
actually stops the hormone
that helps you get
sleepy, called melatonin.
- Okay, yeah see I had
no idea about blue light.
I see.
Actually, a doctor.
(laughing)
Certified.
- What's your YouTube channel?
- Doctor Mike.
- [Kid] Doctor Mike?
Good luck getting famous.
- Thanks, appreciate it.
Do the jiggle, do the jiggle,
do the jiggle!
This is how we stay warm.
(sniffing)
What's her name?
- Pixie.
- Pixie, what's up?
(sniffing)
Pixie, do you have a
medical question for me?
- Is it true that if you get the flu shot,
like getting injected with the flu shot,
- Okay.
- That you're less likely
to actually get the flu?
- Great, I'm so happy you asked.
Like I get hype when
people ask that question.
Yes, you're less likely to get the flu.
In fact, generally, because we have to
predict the strains,
we dropped a percentage that
you're gonna get the flu,
40 to 60%.
And, if you get it, each
consecutive flu season,
the flu shot I mean,
you're gonna get even better results.
Ma'am, would you like
to be in a YouTube video
about health?
- No thanks.
- No, you sure, okay.
- What are you doing?
Like--
- Like what am I doing
on the street?
- Yeah, like--
- I'm really cold.
What are you doing?
What question have you
always wanted to get answered
by a doctor?
Anything, health, nutrition?
Yeah.
- I don't know,
- Come on!
- I jut WebMD everything.
(laughing)
- Yeah, but I'm,
I'm WebMD right now.
- My hands are always cold.
- Okay.
- Literally always cold.
- Always cold?
- Yes, always cold,
why?
- Do they turn blue first of all?
It's a good question
- No.
- for me.
- They're like red.
- Okay, do you have good circulation,
you would think?
- Well see I don't know.
- You don't know?
- No, I--
- What about like
blood flow to your feet?
- Do your feet always get cold?
- Yeah they're always cold.
- Okay.
So, two things can happen.
There's something called
Raynaud's Phenomenon.
Have you heard about that?
- No.
- Okay, so, I'm not
saying that you have this,
and I'm not diagnosing you with this,
but it could be something that's going on.
Reynaud's Phenomenon is when your body
has an overreaction to cold temperature.
Your body wants to preserve warmth, right?
That's how you survive.
So if you go outside
and it's cold somewhere,
your body redirects blood
away from useless things
like your fingers,
and brings it into your organs.
So your body could be having
an overreaction to the cold,
over constricting your blood vessels
in your hands, feet, all that.
And bringing it to your inner organs,
which, is actually a good thing,
because if you're ever
trapped in the wild,
guess who's gonna survive better?
You or someone with warm hands?
- Me?
- Yeah!
There you go.
- So what do you say to
people who've been trying
to lose weight for awhile.
They've been doing a great job,
but they've hit a plateau
- Okay.
- And they're pretty stuck.
- Well a plateau is interesting,
because it actually truly
happens to a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- Especially because fat,
essentially becomes your own organ.
It's kind of weird to
think about it that way,
but it sets up its own blood supply.
It sets up its own hormonal system,
where it actually doesn't
want you to burn it off.
It wants to survive.
So, for those people,
I try and take a look at
what's going on in their life,
outside of their exercise
and nutrition habits.
The thing that people mess up most on,
is sleep, they don't get enough sleep.
- Yeah.
- And then the next thing,
which most people don't think about
with weight loss at all,
is their mental health.
Do you know what the real secret is
to putting on muscle?
- No, tell me.
- Eating enough protein
and calories.
So that's the number one
mistake my patients make.
They'll go to the gym,
they'll do the right exercises,
but they don't eat enough.
Ideally, you'll have one
and a half grams of protein,
per kilogram,
of your body weight.
I'll answer any question, literally.
- [Woman] She's a nurse.
- Oh, also she has all
the answers already.
That's cheating!
- Yeah.
- Well like why do you think a fever
fights off a virus?
- I have no idea.
- See, this is good stuff.
- Yeah, (mumbles) yeah.
- So the reason why we get a fever,
is because viruses can't replicate,
they can't function well
at high temperatures.
- Okay.
- Neither really
can our cells, that's
why we don't like fevers,
- Yeah.
- And we feel rotten,
but, we'd much rather fight off the virus
with this high fever,
allow it to stop replicating,
kill it off and then you can recover
and that's why it takes
a few days afterwards
of getting rid of the symptoms
to even feel 100% well.
- Yeah.
- But, it's good that
we're getting a fever.
That means our immune system is working.
We're fighting things off.
And in general, if you're ever concerned,
the answer is always to
contact your pediatrician,
or family
- Yeah.
- Medicine doctor.
- For sure.
Chocolate.
- Chocolate?
Boom!
(laughing)
Right, good job.
The next day.
Now we're at Venice Boardwalk.
It got a little warmer.
I changed an outfit, changed the venue.
Let's see if we can find some people
to answer some questions.
Bee-woo!
(upbeat music)
Do you have a question?
- We're from Toronto,
Canada.
- Oh, okay.
T-dot, representing,
I love it.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Yeah, we don't call it that anymore.
- Yeah.
- No you don't?
That's, oh am I old?
Is that what's happening?
- I didn't say you were old,
I just said, like, the slang is old.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Got it, okay.
So I need to update it,
what is the sixth?
- Sorry.
Yeah, that's more, or just Toronto.
- What fad diet do you think is legit
for actually losing weight?
- I think that's a trick question,
because you already said
it's a fad diet, so.
All fad diets are really crash diets,
they're not healthy for
you in the long term,
because, for the most part,
people don't stick with them,
because they are crash diets.
The one that's getting some popularity
that I wouldn't call a fad,
that I like personally,
is called intermittent fasting.
- Not a fan.
- No, why is that?
You like eating?
- Yeah, I like eating!
(laughing)
How are you?
I'm a real doctor, answering
people's medical questions.
Do you have any health questions,
you'd like answered?
Where you guys from?
- Russia.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Girl] Super.
(laughing)
- Are you the handsome YouTube doctor?
- Uh, thank you.
I appreciate the compliment.
I believe so (laughs).
- I'll take that as a yeah.
This is my once a year soda.
- Okay.
- I actually cut sugary drinks in 2017.
- Wow!
- And, I feel great.
I drink water.
- Until today.
And then today,
(laughing)
- The one day.
- I meet handsome YouTube doctor.
(laughing)
Like, thanks.
- That's all right.
I'll buy it.
This is a one time, cheat meal.
This is your cheat drink.
- Cheat drink.
I have a question about lipomas.
- Okay, good, good question.
- They're common so I hear.
- Yes.
- I have one of them on my shoulder
and it's been irritating me
with my posture and stuff.
But, I haven't had a chance
to look further into it,
or see what I need to
do to get it removed.
What the procedure's like.
What the costs are like.
- The first step with lipomas,
is to make sure that it is a lipoma.
That takes a doctor taking a look at it
and evaluating, perhaps even poking at it,
doing all sorts of things.
Once you have the diagnosis lipoma,
generally, they don't do anything.
They don't bother you,
until, their size becomes big enough,
that it messes with your posture,
when you lay down, it puts pressure.
Now, here's the tricky part.
Insurance companies technically,
or at least most of the time,
don't pay for a complex lipoma removal,
unless it's causing some other issue.
- I see.
- So when you go see your doctor,
make sure to explain to them that,
this is really bothersome,
it's affecting your sleep,
it's affecting your quality of life,
because only then will
the insurance company say,
"Okay then the risk is worth the benefit."
- Understood.
- Yeah.
So that's a little strategy piece
for lipomas.
- That's an extremely
helpful tip.
- Why, so many doctors say
they find this cure for cancer,
and so many kids been crying out for help?
What about the medication
for the younger youths
there now, what about that?
- One of the--
- For cancer.
- One of the biggest problems
with cancer research,
is that we're putting all
the money to do research
for adult cancers and not enough money
goes to research for children's cancers.
Isn't that crazy?
- Oh!
- That we research
more adult cancers than
children's cancers.
The idea though,
and my hope is,
that by finding the cure for one cancer,
or making treatment for one cancer,
we can then use that for
other cancers as well.
It's not gonna work for all of them,
but I'm hoping that's the case.
- All the things that you
find in different stuff,
it's just one thing,
because it's just nuncas.
- Yeah.
- So cancer, Aids, whatever.
Is nuncas, so.
You know,
- Describe what nuncas is.
- One you don't go to,
- Tell me what that is.
- Doctor says (mumbles) check on this
- Yeah.
- For (mumbles)
what he's using to cure all these
- Describe nuncas.
- Aids, cancers.
- What is that, teach me.
- Nuncas, is just nuncas.
You don't, you're a doctor?
- Yeah, I don't know what that is.
- Well you know (mumbles).
- But I wanna know,
so tell me.
- You know it,
no, you know it.
- Oh I do, okay.
(chill music)